clint black is a country music legend he
has sold over 20 million records he's
won some grammys and he can now see him
at the edgewater casino resort in
laughlin on july 9th and he joins us now
this is huge hey clint how's it going
hey jc looking good
great so you got a big show in laughlin
what do you do to get ready for a show
can you just walk out on stage and go or
is there some practice and rehearsing
ahead of time
a little jet skiing on the river and
then i'm good to go uh now i have a
pretty strict routine it's uh just
getting prepared with my instruments
warming up my vocal cords
playing the guitar until uh you know my
hands feel good and strong
and uh and it's
you know uh and then you know just tell
myself you know those daily affirmations
you know
uh you're gonna do fine
you're gonna have fun
and uh people it's it's better than
sports you know people you know
i don't know if i've ever been booed
maybe i blocked it out but uh you know
everyone's friendly uh we have a great
time well laughlin's a great town to see
a show and i have to ask you about the
iconic black hat of yours do you ever
not have the hat on every time i see you
i mean that is your look that is who you
are you ever go out like grocery
shopping with no hat
you know
i'll have a ball cap on or uh but yeah
i'll go i'll go without a hat um the
reason for the black cat though is in
anyone in fashion knows this it makes my
head look thinner
i need to get one of those i need to get
myself a black hat you have you have so
many hit songs so many songs do you
remember all of your songs do you know
the lyrics to all of your songs or
there's some where someone brings it up
like i didn't write that
i've written over 150 songs and uh
if i had to go back and dig into some
deep cuts i would have to have a
refresher
what can we expect at this show gonna
play all the hits what we expected the
show coming up on july 9th it's a very
good show according to me we uh we were
doing bare bones stuff for a while and
we've upped the production so we've got
video screens i created and edited all
of the stage video content we got a
great band they get to play
now just because the singer shuts up
doesn't mean the song is over we've got
great musicians who really get to
stretch out and play it's mostly hits
there's a couple of deep cuts that are
fan favorites
and uh you know and the more intimate
venues you know i've got some some
funniest sides we have some big laughs i
mean i'm kind of geeking out here i'm
talking to clint black right now you are
country royalty a music icon so many
singers and people look up to you who is
it for you what are the singers that you
looked up to throughout your career
uh well there's some great vocalists and
then they're great artists and great
songwriters you know merle haggard
willie whalen
uh buck
you know um
then james taylor jimmy buffett
uh you know i'm a big fan of classic
rock so yeah i think the country and the
classic rock list would be obvious
um you know but singers who were
songwriters who were great vocalists
like kenny loggins you know really had
an impact on me
uh trying to mimic them or toy caldwell
of marshall tucker band trying to hit
those high notes like they do
clint thank you so much we appreciate
your time and the show is going to be
awesome you have a great day we'll see
you down in laughlin clint black at the
edgewater casino resorts in laughlin
saturday july 9 for tickets visit
edgewatercasino.com
mercedes over to you